ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass wir
uns in der Energiepolitik im Moment auf
dem Holzweg befinden es ist vieles was
keine Logik in sich wirkt vor allem
gerade auch im Hinblick darauf dass uns
erst die Augen so richtig geöffnet
wurden durch diese schlimme Katastrophe
in der Ukraine und dem Wegfall dieser
gasbrücke die wir bis dahin hatten ich
kann nur für
diesen diesen Standort in Deutschland
dann erhalten mit unserem Wohlstand mit
der Sicherheit und auch mit bezahlbarer
Energie und deshalb stellt sich für mich
die Frage wie man so unlogisch dran
gehen kann und sagen kann dass 10 bis
15% der grundlastfähigen Erzeugung
auskennen Energie aus den sicheren
Kernkraftwerken die seit 60 Jahren in
Deutschland laufen und bei denen nichts
passiert ist jetzt zu einer Abschaltung
führen sollen im Gegenteil ich bin der
Meinung man müsste die drei bereits
abgeschalteten aber noch mit einer
Betriebserlaubnis versehenen Kraftwerke
wieder ans Netz bringen